foreign
[Music]
and welcome to safety Ridge on Sunday
it's exactly 90 days since Rishi sunak
became prime minister and when he first
stood on the steps of Downing Street he
promised a government of Integrity
replacing constant scandals with
competence the kind of leader who would
welcome politics becoming a bit more
boring well the problem is it really
hasn't worked out like that and this
morning exemplifies that with a focus on
the taxes of his party chairman and
allegations of a loan guarantee to Boris
Johnson arranged by the man he appointed
to chair the BBC who would want to be
the government Minister on today's show
well in a few moments we'll be talking
to that man James cuddly the foreign
secretary will be on the program this
morning and for labor the shadow Chief
secretary to the treasury Pat McFadden
will be talking to us in the studio now
there are yet more ambulance strikes in
the coming days unite members are part
of that and plenty of other action
across the public sector we'll talk to
the Union's general secretary Sharon
Graham
and the war in Ukraine is almost a year
old its impact is being felt by
countries across the globe we'll bring
you a stark warning from the president
of the World Bank David malpas
and after another dark week for the
reputation of British policing we'll
speak to the man who investigated the
culture at the country's biggest fire
service the former Chief Crown
prosecutor Nazir afsal
[Music]
well let's start with that pressure on
the government this morning labor is
calling for the conservative party chair
at Nadeem zahawi to go after what he
described as a careless but not
deliberate error over unpaid tax and
reports that he had to pay a penalty and
the opposition also won an investigation
into allegations of loan guarantees
worth eight hundred thousand pounds
given to former prime minister Boris
Johnson arranged according to the Sunday
Times by the man that he appointed to
chair the BBC while both Richard Sharp
and the former prime minister deny any
claims of a conflict of interest
we can speak now to the foreign
secretary James cleverley thank you for
being on the show this morning
now the last thing that I read uh before
I went to bed last night was a tweet
that said thoughts and prayers to
whoever is doing the media around
tomorrow were you tempted to pull out
uh look I
um I'm the foreign Secretary of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland I am the face and voice
of
um the UK on the international stage I'm
very pleased to be able to come on your
show tell you about what I've been up to
on behalf of the people of this great
country and also on behalf of our
friends and allies particularly the uh
the ukrainians who are defending
themselves so hard against Russian uh
Invasion so always always a pleasure to
join you on the show now we will talk
about Ukraine um but I'm sure you'll be
aware that we do need to start with the
serious allegations around integrity and
the government I want to start with a
story that's what we call in the
business a marmalade dropper according
to the Sunday Times in 2020 when Boris
Johnson was prime minister Richard Sharp
helped him to arrange a guarantee on an
800 000 pound loan now shortly after
Boris Johnson recommended him for the
job at BBC chairman which he then got
is that true
well I don't uh I I I've not had a
conversation with either of those
parties uh about that about that
situation I have met with Richard we uh
discussed uh the World Service he struck
me as an incredibly uh competent uh
experienced thoughtful uh individual
um and I uh I can see exactly why he has
the attributes both personal and
professional to be the uh chair of the
of the BBC so uh as far as I can see his
appointment was made on those uh on
those merits
um and he has said and uh and from from
and I take this from the intro that you
just given uh that there you know he
denies there being any uh conflict of
interest let's say I can see the uh I
can see the Merit I can see the
experience that he brings to the job
you know you say that you haven't spoken
to Boris Johnson or Richard Sharp I just
really wonder if that's good enough I
mean you're close to Boris Johnson
you've got his phone number why don't
you text him
well I'm sure you've got his phone
number as well Sophie um
you're not uh well
um well look as I say the the fact of
the matter is that Richard is
undoubtedly an incredibly uh experienced
uh uh individual uh steps into this role
with
um as say both personal professional
attributes which qualify him for the job
and we've had senior people in the uh in
the BBC
um who have uh you know political
affiliations most people have uh
political affiliations a number of them
are active so it's not at all unusual to
have uh individuals in the senior levels
of the BB just to just to jump in
because the problem the the concern here
isn't because of political affiliation
the concern people have is that there is
a serious report here that Mr Sharp
helped to guarantee a loan of eight
hundred thousand pounds to a man who
then recommended him for the job and you
are saying that you don't know if it's
true or not because you haven't tried to
find out and you know it might be easy
for you to be able to come here and say
look I don't know I wasn't to do with it
but it's not great for transparency is
it
well look you're the journalist not me I
mean it's not I mean my role as foreign
secretary is as I say to be the face and
voice of this country on the world stage
on the actions of our government and on
behalf of our people
um and you know as I say I've met
Richard I've spoke with him about the
BBC World Service which of course is the
part of the BBC which is of most
directly relevance uh relevant to uh my
department the functions of my
department
um I didn't have
um and there's no reason why I would
have conversations with him or the Prime
Minister about this particular thing
because as I say uh anyone that looks at
his CV you can see he has a wealth of
experience with large organizations and
of course you know the uh the fact of
the matter is there are plenty of people
also say who are or have been senior
within the BBC who have a political link
so there's nothing wrong with that uh
the appointment clearly is one that
requires someone of huge experience
which it has that experience and
therefore
um you know if he says that there's
there's no conflict of interest uh I
know it's it's quite tempting to say
well hang on a second he's he's been a
donor
um and that's what I'm saying I I wanna
I wanna be really clear that it's
absolutely not what I'm saying here I'm
talking about the specific allegation
that he helped to guarantee an 800 000
pound loan to the Prime Minister who
Weeks Later
recommended him for the job if that is
true
I'll say about the character in
Integrity of Boris Johnson
well as I say I don't know the details
about you're you're you're putting these
things forward I've not had the chance
to validate that I'm not pulling into
question of course
um uh you know the uh the Integrity of
any of the people involved in that
reporting I just don't know the detail
of that what I do know is that Richard
steps into that job with a huge
repository of wealth uh and experience
this was a point that this was an
appointment made uh by uh
um you know my predecessor sorry the the
prime minister's predecessor but one
um but Richard does have a huge wealth
of experience and as I say it is not
unusual for senior appointments into the
BBC to be uh uh to go to people who have
um you know linked to the political
parties
okay well this story broke uh yesterday
in the Sunday Times let's talk about a
story that broke a week ago in the sun
on Sunday so hopefully you might have a
bit more information on this for us
the party chairman Nadim zahawi still of
course in cabinet we know that he made a
settlement with hmrc over his tax
Affairs how much was that settlement for
well the only information I know that is
I know about this is the information
that he's put out in his statement
um now you know Nadeem was a very very
successful uh entrepreneur
um he you know as as he said in his
statement
um had an outstanding settlement with
the hmrc which is now settled
um and I mean I don't I don't have any
more details than he's put in his public
statement
okay so we don't know how much the
settlement was for with hmrc did he pay
a penalty
well again I don't know any more than is
in his statement
um and the hmrc uh the the words that
they used was this was uh this was an
error this was careless rather than
that's not the words hmrcs that's words
that Nadeem zaha we use as in his
statement
well my understanding is that that was
the that that reflects the
um the position that HMS hmrc took
towards this situation
so you say that all you know is what's
in Nadim zahawi's statement that was
made yesterday there are two pretty
critical bits of information that
weren't in the statement a how much does
that moment was for and B
whether he paid a penalty or not do you
not think that Nadim zahari needs to
come out and give us these facts these
very simple facts
well I mean
we we know that Nadeem was a very
successful businessman before he came
into politics credibly uh successful uh
Minister particularly in his role as
vaccines Minister
um but ultimately you know people's
taxpayers in this country that you know
people's taxpayers are private matters
and I know that as politicians we uh
quite rightly are expected to have a
higher level of disclosure than perhaps
other people might do uh Nadine has
um issued a statement where he has
admitted that he made a careless error
that this is now resolved with the uh
Aussie
um
speculating about other people's
personal finances
um even uh and as even though I totally
understand the fact that that we are
expected to be
um I think
um you know more open than other people
in society would be in the he has been
more open than others would be he's made
the point yeah
domain it was a son on Sunday who put
this information in the public domain
and since then I'll be honest I'm not
clear you know how much the settlement
was for whether he paid a penalty you
know I'm not sure he has been clear if
we haven't been told the simple
information and also to be honest I'm
really not sure it's good enough either
you know there'll be millions of people
who will be witnessing this story people
people watching this morning as well who
you know are all struggling to make ends
meet they still pay their taxes on time
they pay the correct amount of tax don't
they have a right to know whether a
member of the government made a
settlement with hmrc how much it was for
and if he was paid a penalty
well I think what people have seen is
that Nadeem had been a very successful
uh entrepreneur and business person but
this is completely this is not that's
not the question we're not asking about
his success outside outside we're asking
about his tax Affairs and it's still
just really not clear
no I think it is relevant because it's
it's worth remembering but uh whatever
whatever tax uh um uh he was he was
required to pay was a direct byproduct
of the fact that he created a business
a successful business which employed
people uh and you know that business
would have paid tax those individuals
would have paid taxes Nadim has paid
taxes been a huge contributor to the UK
economy as well as being a very very
effective Minister particularly in that
incredibly difficult time where he used
his business uh experience in the
management of the vaccine roll out he
has said that an arrow was made but that
is now fully resolved
um and and as I say you know the fact
that this is in the uh is in the public
domain is something that you wouldn't
normally expect
um
um you know other people necessarily to
to go through but I totally recognize as
politicians we do quite legitimately
have an increased
um uh interest and focus and increased
expectation of transparency because say
nadina said that this money uh has been
uh sorry his relationship with the hmrc
has been settled in full
um and I don't know any more details
beyond what was interesting
he says that he made an error
he was careless
I mean you're careless if you you know
Miss A self-assessment deadline by a
week you're careless if you spill the
milk when you're making a cup of tea
you're not careless if reportedly you
end up paying a million pound penalty to
hmrc are you
well there's there's process and there's
and there's uh magnitude I mean you say
that you know people do make errors
um and uh when those errors are
highlighted
um some people try to avoid making uh
making it right or doing the right thing
and others do the right thing the dean's
done the right thing
um in his statement the Dooms are Harvey
says when I was being appointed
Chancellor of the exchequer questions
were being raised about my tax Affairs I
discussed this with a cabinet office at
the time
when Nadim zahari was Chancellor was he
under investigation by hmrc
well as I say I I don't know any more
detail about the timing about the
granularity of this
be almost in uh his his statement but
the point is this is not this is not
granularity this is the question about
whether the chancellor the man who is
literally in charge of tax
ation by hmrc over his taxes and you
don't know if that's true or not I mean
that you can see how that looks right
well as I say the detail I have is the
detail that Nadine has put out in his
public statement
um and the point I've made is that this
tax was due because he was a successful
entrepreneur who grew a business from
nothing
um he came to this country with nothing
as you know his his backstory uh
escaping a violence persecution and
possible death in Iraq coming to this
country uh with nothing
um unable to speak English and he built
a very very successful uh company uh
employing people and that is why these
uh that is why these uh um taxes were
due and ultimately he in you know uh you
know conversation with hmrc uh came to
uh came to the arrangement whereby those
taxes were were fully paid
um and I think that that is yeah and as
I say I can't guess and I won't
speculate about more detail than that
but the point is
um he has said that it was an error and
he is now fully up to date with the hmrc
he says that he discussed it with a
cabin office when he was made Chancellor
when was Rishi sunak aware of questions
shall we say concerns over Nadim
zahawi's tax affairs
you know the answer that question
already because I've already said I
don't know any more detail than is in
his public statement so if you're asking
me for more detail than in his public
statement I'm not I'm not able to give
you that detail I know that might be
frustrating but as I say I don't know
any more about the entertainment isn't
it it's very convenient I mean I'll be
honest I just you know most people would
expect if you're coming out to be the
front of the government this morning to
to be aware if you know the guy when he
was Chancellor was under investigation
by hmrc when the Prime Minister knew
about these allegations you would expect
to have done that research now
um my job is as foreign secretary as I
say the what I've done this week is is
is work on behalf of the government this
is not I'm not I I'm not an investigator
I'm not an investigative journalist and
um and I'm not uh uh you know and I'm
I'm not uh it's not my functional role
to investigate my colleagues uh tax
Affairs
um my you know my desire to come on the
show this morning was because yeah I
wanted to talk about the world that the
UK uh sorry the work that the UK is
doing on the world stage the uh the
position that we're taking with regards
to the defense of Ukraine we'll we'll
talk about Ukraine we're talking about
Ukraine one final question on the deems
the highway
will he survive until prime minister's
questions on Wednesday
I knew inevitably that I would have to
speak about other uh issues as well but
there is a wide range of things that I'm
dealing with just in my portfolio and as
I say I should say I will literally talk
about Ukraine after you answer this
question will and deems are how we
survive until prime minister's questions
well well I mean look that's that's the
kind of question that's designed to get
a nice little uh commit
um because
um you know it's it's it's I mean what
answer I'm going to say other than yes
because he's a very very effective
Minister he has been he has shown
himself to be
um uh you know very very successful
business business number four coming
into politics taking that business
experience into uh his role as uh
vaccines Minister
um so you know it it it is clear white
he has been appointed to senior
positions within the government because
he has
um demonstrated Effectiveness in both
private sector and public sector
throughout his career
okay well let's talk about Ukraine uh
shall we the story that I would have
started this interview uh on if it
hadn't been for the two allegations
about members of the cabinet now the UK
has pledged to send Challenger two tanks
to Ukraine should Germany send tanks as
well
well we want to make sure that the
ukrainians Prevail we want to make sure
that that is done quickly because that
is the best way of saving as many lives
as possible the United Kingdom has been
very much at the Forefront of a
supporting Ukraine with military
equipment since before The Invasion
started and we continue to do so with
the announcement of those Challenger 2
tanks as well as a whole range of other
military donations of course we continue
to liaise with our International
Partners
um we we would like to see uh everybody
going as far as they can but each
country will support Ukraine in a way
that is most appropriate to them of
course we have I have been talking on
the international stage about the
provision of armored vehicles including
tanks to Ukraine because that is what
they are telling us that they need to
defeat Russia in the east and south of
their country and that's what they're
saying is Germany as well isn't it and
it's significant because just you know
the German Leopold two tanks are seen as
a potential game changer for Ukraine so
they're easy to maintain they're
designed specifically to be effective
against Russian tanks last week on the
program I spoke to a Ukrainian MP lesia
vasilenko who basically said Germany
isn't doing enough do you think she's
right
well Germany has done a huge amount
already
um and it's worth it's you know it's
worth remembering that they come from a
very different starting point in terms
of their defense posture compared to the
the uh
um and you know I have been talking with
my International counterparts about the
provision of military equipment
particularly The Leopard 2 tank which is
an incredibly effective piece of
equipment of course I would like to see
the ukrainians
um equipped with things like leopard two
um as well as the you know artillery
systems that have been provided by us
and by others I will keep having those
conversations with our NATO allies and
Friends uh to to facilitate the donation
of the the best military equipment uh to
Ukraine to help them defend themselves
against this um this brutal invasion now
the war in Ukraine is having a huge
impact on well every country in the
world but in particularly some of the
poorest Nations when it comes to the
rising price of food in particular and I
spoke to the president of the World Bank
uh this week we'll hear the interview a
little bit later on the program who was
concerned about the level of debt uh
that some of these poorest Nations have
and he said that the wealthy countries
should think about writing off some of
that debt do you think he's got a point
well look
um the desire for the debt write-off is
something that is discussed
um uh regularly uh it's one of those
things that is a compelling as a
headline but they're fast and practical
uh challenges with regards to the
provision of future debt
um if
um you know if there is a belief that
that will be written off particularly
when public sector money is leveraging
in private sectors but the simple truth
is that the the global South the poorer
countries in the world are suffering
because directly because of Russia's
invasion of Ukraine
um the UK we very much supported the uh
Ukrainian grain initiative which saw
Ukrainian brain exports coming out of
the Black Sea directly to some of the
poorest countries in the world indeed I
was in Northern Ethiopia which is
suffering it's 50 years of failed rain
to see Ukrainian grains distributed by
world food program trucks which had been
supplied using UK Aid and development
money so we will continue to support the
um the provision of of food to the
global South who are suffering because
of Russia's as a brutal and unjustified
invasion of Ukraine okay um we are at a
time
um it's been a tough uh morning around
but you are the one from the government
fronting up answering questions on this
so we do appreciate your time thank you
thank you Sophie thank you very much
James cleverley out there for the
government well let's get Labor's take
on all of that now uh shall we we're
joined by the shadow Chief secretary to
the treasury Department Saturn thank you
very much for being on the program uh
today
um I know you were across the James
cleverley interview what's your reaction
to it
but look I wish we were talking about
other things
um you know we might do as well things
to say yesterday about the cost of
living crisis and energy bills and so on
uh
I think the problem with these things if
you take these different stories
together is that it's very easy for the
public to conclude they're all the same
they're all in it for themselves and I
think with the Boris Johnson stuff
he almost relies on that level of
cynicism uh so that people conclude no
Scandal matters nothing matters because
that's what they'll like anyway and I
feel more than the individual cases this
is really corrosive to governance and
government or a big problem space in the
country we need good government and I
think it's it'd be a tragedy if the
result of all this was for people to
just simply turn away from politics and
say they're all a bunch of crooks and
naves now in important to say Boris
Johnson spokesperson says the story is
rubbish that Richard Sharp didn't give
me any Financial advice there hasn't
been any remuneration for Richard charm
you've reported Boris Johnson to the
Parliamentary commissioner for standards
why have you done that
we've done that because we think this
needs to be looked into Boris Johnson's
spokesperson said so what big deal which
actually sums up his whole response to
all of these things over the last couple
of years on the specifics of this the
allegation is that the chairman of the
BBC acted as a broker to uh help
facility a loan of 800 000 pounds to
Boris Johnson while he was a candidate
to become the chairman of the BBC that's
not just labor that said this we
understand the cabinet office actually
intervened to say that this Arrangement
couldn't continue because he was a
candidate to become chairman of the BBC
so obviously that big big questions
about what was going on here and that's
why we've made that reference now
Richard Sharp says that there wasn't a
conflict of interest we heard James
cleverley there saying that Richard
Sharp is a man of you know great
integrity that he understands why he was
given the role
is the BBC impartial
well look
you know I'm not here to have a pop in
the BBC but I do think it's pretty
extraordinary if someone who is running
to be the chairman ends up acting as a
broker to help the prime minister of the
day out of whatever financial
difficulties he was in at the very least
that should all have been declared and
brought into the open there's nothing in
Boris Johnson's Declaration of entrance
as an MP about this
it's been brought into the open by
journalism not by people being
transparent and that's why I do think
this does need to be looked into okay as
you say
um you're calling from the investigation
they say uh that the story isn't
accurate so we'll see how that goes
um let's talk about Nadeem zahawi uh
shall we um James cleverly says that he
will survive tool prime minister's
questions on Wednesday what's your take
I think it's difficult for uh Mr zahawi
because the the problem with this is
what we've been asked to believe and
uh would be nice to believe that he had
the SASE worth 27 million pounds that he
didn't really know was his and therefore
didn't we know tax was due on it and the
thing about his statement issued
yesterday is he was using pretty heavy
legal letters to try to get people to be
quiet about this back in July
to don't need all the tax expert who
exposed some of this to newspapers like
the independent threatening legal action
and then we're asked to believe that
it's all just carelessness that doesn't
quite fit so
I think this is quite difficult for them
though
um
he knew James cleverly said look I don't
know anything about this all I know is
what is in the deem zahawi's statement
and but he's obviously you know cabinet
minister he's a party chairman under
Rishi sunak it's a problem for the Prime
Minister too
well I think it is because when he came
into office he promised a new broom and
all this that after the Boris Johnson
days when proprietary and ethics had
been in the news almost every day
through one Scandal or another
uh that he would you know turn over our
new Leaf to be a new page and so on so I
think this is a test of that uh and if
you've got someone who is negotiating
all this while he was the chancellor
threatening people with uh legal action
and then coming to the conclusion that
uh he's owed millions of pounds uh to
the to the tax uh man and probably with
a penalty in it as well we we don't know
for sure but it looks that way
I think this is a question for the Prime
Minister as well because what does that
New Broom that turning the page on the
propriety and ethics questions mean if
this is just Shrugged off and we should
say of course new teams are how we
statement Point towards his statement
yesterday where he says that his taxes
are you know now up to date that he
reached the settlement with hmrc to do
that
do you think that actually we're getting
to a stage now where high profile
politicians should actually just publish
their tax returns maybe they should I've
got no problem with that
um what what concerns me more about us
is what I said at the beginning that the
public will just conclude everybody's
utter in some way well that's the way to
to counter that though right conspiracy
it may be on tax as I say you know I
would have no problem with that but
these scandals are not just about tax
returns with Boris Johnson question that
we're discussing today is about
something else what I'm more concerned
with is that people give up on politics
and that would be really bad for the
country because there are plenty serious
issues that need good governance and
need politics to address them the cost
of living crisis is one the situation in
the NHS is another there is plenty to be
doing here and I don't want people to
think politics can't have any solutions
because they're all in it for themselves
well let's talk about some of those
serious issues now uh shall we and the
NHS you mentioned we of course seen the
strike action
from nurses and ambulance workers too
we'll be talking to unite Sharon Graham
shortly
nurses have signaled that they would
accept a pay rise of around 10 would
labor grant that
I've been doing interviews on this for
three months and every time a journalist
has asked me what's the percentage I've
had to point out this has got to be
negotiated between the employers the
government and the union I'm not going
to give a percentage today the important
thing is that staff in these sectors get
a decent pay rise then because these
straights generally what what do you
think is a decent payment you know it
has to be negotiated I'm not going to
give us a figure but you just said that
staff need to be given a decent pay
literally what is a DC well that's got
to be negotiation inflation that's got
to be negotiated around the uh the table
obviously it has to be negative that's
clearly a fact but I just wonder you
know if you say that journalists have
been asking you this question for three
months do you think that's because we're
not getting an answer we don't know what
label we give is a fair pay rise two
percent is it February is 12 I could
name any percent you want to do yeah
that'd be great actually thank you 20 50
and the fact is because clear enough
position it doesn't get the nurses an
extra point it might do a lot to help
them if labor came out with a policy no
labor coming out with a percentage
doesn't make any difference to these
strikes what would make a difference in
the longer term is a government a really
backed public services and that's what
we did when we were in government we
didn't have these uh strikes we managed
to give people both decent pay Rises and
fund the Public Services properly and
that's what we'll do if we get elected
because
it's a problem if you're from the public
services properly then would you be
prepared to give more money to the NHS
the problem for the NHS is not just the
current industrial dispute the problem
for the NHS is that even when there
isn't a straight day we've got seven
million people on waiting lists so what
we've said is Staffing us at the heart
of this we need to train more doctors we
need to train more nurses we need to
change the way the system works our
ambition isn't just to save this service
is to renew it for the future we've said
how we'll do that we've said how we'll
fund that there's got to be a longer
term solution to Public Services other
than just a short-term ambition to get
through the strikes sure but I guess
what the nurses Unions would say is that
it's not just a short-term ambition this
is all about the workforce right and the
people feel that they're not getting
paid a fair amount then they're going to
leave which is what's happening right
now they've got a recruitment crisis and
I have to say you know labor say look
you know we get around the table and
negotiate we would be given a fair deal
to nurses but if you look at the actual
meat of what you're saying
I can't work out how it's different from
the government because you won't put a
figure on on what you do
I figured from my position it'd be
pretty meaningless because we're not a
party to the negotiations when we were
in government we managed to negotiate
decent payorises for NHS staff and fund
the service properly you know these days
they're talking about an ambition of
getting a GP appointment in two weeks
when we were in office it was within 40
hours that's the difference that can be
made but I've got to also be honest with
your viewers
after 13 years the situation that we
inherit won't be turned around overnight
it will take time to rebuild the NHS and
that's why we put this issue of Staffing
and training more doctors and nurses at
the heart of our proposals because there
is no solution to the long-term problems
of the NHS without addressing Staffing p
is an issue of course it's an issue with
inflation running at the levels it is
today it's not just about pay it's about
short staffing on Wards it's about
waiting lists with just not enough
people in the service to deal with them
so we need to deal with that and renew
the NHS so that it can really be the
21st century Health Service that we need
okay thank you very much for being on
the program at this morning
for the labor party now you're watching
at safe Ridge on a Sunday busy show
today lots of interviews so far not
least of course with James cleverley who
said he wasn't going to get into the
granular detail of Nadine's holidays at
tax affairs plus apartment pattern there
talking about Labor's response now in
just a moment we're going to be talking
to the General Secretary of the United
Union Sharon Graham and a little later
on the program we're also going to be
hearing from the president of the World
Bank David marpal so that's an
interesting one too plus we'll get a bit
of a reaction from our Deputy political
editor Sam Coates who's been watching
all of our interviews we are going to be
speaking at Sam a little bit later as
well
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
well despite the scandals that we've
been talking about uh today the main
challenge facing the Prime Minister and
the country of course one of the main
challenges is the strikes crisis
ambulance staff and nurses will be
walking out again in the coming days and
weeks as the NHS faces what many uh view
as its most difficult winter in living
memory and there's no deal in sight of
course for teachers or potentially uh on
the railways too well we're joined Now
by The General Secretary of the United
Union Sharon Graham thanks very much for
being uh with us
we spent an awful lot of time on the
program today talking about Nadeem
zahawi's tax Affairs or loans taken out
by Boris Johnson are you worried that
this is effectively a distraction for
the government totally because it's
woeful listening to this because of
course the big issue now is the NHS and
what is going to happen in relation to
the NHS and I've heard government
ministers coming on different programs
your programs other programs literally
saying that they are in talks with
unions and there has been no talks with
unions and so we're still in exactly the
same position that we've been in for
weeks there's another strike Tomorrow
there's an escalation of strikes over
the coming weeks and Rishi sunak I have
to say is missing in action I don't know
where he is he should be getting around
the table he is the CEO of this company
if you were talking about negotiating
terms he is the key decision maker it's
clear Stephen Barkley cannot make a
decision now it's either that Rishi
sunak is not up to this job that he
doesn't want to come into the
negotiating room and to do this deal or
there must be another reason as to why
he's allowing this self-harm to happen
to the NHS there have been some talks
though right Stephen Buckley has been
talking to some union members right but
they're not pay talks and this is the
problem the big issue here is about pay
um there is an issue where the ambulance
workers the the nurses the NHS are
saying we need a pay rise the public is
supporting that pay rise as we can see
from surveys and we've got the employer
in this instance the government who will
talk about anything but they won't talk
about paying years pay rise right but
that's not the one that's gone well
that's not what the dispute is about the
dispute is about 22.23 but they haven't
made any offer Sophie this is the
scenario I mean I negotiate every day of
my life I'm in the rooms with CEOs all
the time we know what it does and what
has to happen to have deals happen
um this employer being the government is
not interested in doing a deal as far as
the NHS is concerned and I have to say
we are concluding now that there must be
a much more Sinister reason for this
because this level of self-harm is
unprecedented the public are crying out
I came here at a cab this morning and
the cab driver was saying why don't they
just give a pay rise to the NHS
everybody wants that to happen it's
almost like there is another reason for
them doing what they're doing because
it's total incompetence otherwise what
do you think that reason this one well I
think that they are looking to privatize
the NHS genuinely I believe that they're
they're looking as this is the moment
they can privatize the NHS I said when I
was on your program the last time that I
was very concerned about the chancellor
who was the health secretary who wanted
the NHS in the American trade deal and
there was a big fight about making sure
it wasn't in the American trade deal
there is something unusual going on here
that they will not come to the table
there are choices that can be made that
means we can pay for this that is not
there is not a problem about paying with
the fifth richest country in the world
there is something going on here
otherwise they are a level of
incompetence not known I mean because
it's unreal it's a big claim to say the
government is looking to privatize the
NHS and that goes against everything
that they've said about the NHS
remaining free at the point of view so I
mean labor prepared accountants more
private sector involvement in the NHS
right now than the government you know
do you have any evidence to back this up
because I guess what they would say is
look at the at the minute we're spending
more on debt interest than education
this is why there has to be paying
restraint well actually speak louder
than words to me so words you know words
are cheap
um there is a crisis in the NHS they can
come to the table and negotiate on this
crisis all the general secretaries
including may have said we will be there
any time any place anywhere we'll cancel
any meeting to be there in that room
here's the CEO of this group of workers
and he refuses to come to the table now
it's either that he doesn't know what to
do when he gets to that table I mean
maybe he doesn't know how to negotiate I
don't know maybe it's that there is
another issue going on but we have to
look at what's happening why would they
not be coming to the table and deal with
this issue everyone is crying out for
them to get this issue solved and unless
they solve the issue of workers and the
crisis of workers in NHS and those
people leaving the NHS we will never be
able to get the NHS back on its knees
and they know that how long could these
strikes go on for well I hope that they
are resolved very very quickly and but
the problem is and you know when you're
in a negotiation two parties have to
speak and they have to come out with a
deal and then that deal will go back to
the membership we have not had any deal
to take back to the membership they went
around different Studios Before
Christmas saying they were going to
offer things it was nearly there you
know glimmers of hope I didn't have that
warm fuzzy feeling of hope I have to
tell you because I've seen this many
times before they haven't even offered a
deal so they are they're being
disingenuous by pretending that there
are talks going on about pay
significantly about pay there are
absolutely no talks going on about pay
every General Secretary will tell you
that do you think part of the issue is
that initially some of the proposals
were what the government would describe
as clearly unaffordable 90 for nurses
for example well that tells me they
don't understand negotiation obviously
there is an opening situation where a
claim is tabled
um I think it's really clear that what
we're talking about is a pay rise in the
double-digit pay rise that's what we're
talking about the RCN have already said
they'd meet them halfway I don't know
how much more hints do they want to take
on that and so it's a double-digit pay
rise if they came in the room and they
offered a double-digit pay rise we would
take that back to our members and our
members would make the decision but
they're not doing that they are playing
with words dancing around their Handbags
and they're not coming and doing the
deal they need to do to get the NHS back
working now we're having rolling strikes
in NHS nurses ambulance workers at a
time when we all know the NHS is under a
law depression right
do accept that that is putting people's
lives at risk well I'd say about that is
that their lives are at risk already 500
people a week I mean just think of that
number because we say numbers very
quickly 500 people a week are dying
waiting for ambulances 500 a week that
is unbelievable in a country like ours
people are dying if we don't take this
stand and we don't sort out what's going
on in the NHS it will crash and die and
so therefore this strike yes it's about
pay absolutely 100 it's about pay and I
think people want the NHS to get a pay
rise but it's also about the NHS itself
and it's on its knees unless we can get
more people working in it it will not
survive so it's a strike to save the NHS
as well as get a good pay rise for
workers the strike obviously has an
impact uh too
um that's certainly the view of Amanda
Pritchard the chief executive of NHS
England who said in an interview this
week as the strike action is extended
over long periods of time and as those
dates start coming closer to together it
does get more challenging there is
absolutely no doubt it is clearly having
an impact I think that's obvious
yes absolutely and of course what we do
in strikes and you know this is what we
do across the board in the NHS is that
we put safety guarantees in so I was on
the picket line the West Midlands for
the ambulance dispute I'm on the picket
line tomorrow in the Northwest for the
ambulance dispute and we negotiate
safety cover in relation to those
disputes it's never going to be as good
as it well
if we're talking about 500 people a week
as you say according to the uh you know
acute medicine people they say that that
is that's 500 people a week up to 500
people dying because of delays of
ambulances if ambulance workers go on
strike
that's gonna have an impact but we are
putting in safety levels that mean it
doesn't have as much as an impact and
that is actually the irony here we could
be in a situation which we were on the
21st where it was safer on the 21st than
it was in normal play because we are in
minimum service levels anyway there's
130 000 people missing from the NHS and
to be honest with you Sophie what has to
happen here is quite a simple solution
the government all they need to do is to
come to the table let's do a negotiation
we come out of the room we put it to the
members they ballot and then everyone's
back to work it's a very simple thing
this has been drawn out for weeks and
weeks and weeks and you have to think is
this deliberate is it deliberate are you
saying that ministers are effectively
lying then when they say that they are
yes I am saying that and the ministers
have been lying on a number of issues
and normally I wouldn't use that word
you know it's not really a word that we
would use we tend to dance around that
word a lot but I have to tell you the
the stuff that's been said about
ambulance workers and them not covering
minimum safety levels on dispute was a
lie and I'll say very clearly it was a
lie the stuff that's been trotted out I
did something last week and the
government's response was we're in talks
that is a lie they are absolutely not in
Pay talks and this is the problem that
we haven't got an honest partner at the
other side of the table you know
normally you go into a negotiation yes
you have Archie Barger you don't always
agree you don't get everything you want
that is life but you know that the
person on the other side of the table
wants resolution I'm negotiating with
somebody at the moment that I don't
think wants resolution and that's a real
problem I'll have to say listening like
whatever the you know the truth listen
to you now it does feel like that deal
is an awful long way off and just before
I spoke to you I respected of Labor I
was trying to get a sense about what
labor would do if they were in
government right now what pay rise they
would see as Fair he said that you know
he's not going to give a number it that
would be meaningless it wouldn't make
any difference is he right or do you
think it would be helpful if labor
actually would be clear on what they
would do well look labor aren't in
government so he's right about that but
obviously they're in opposition so I
have to say you know I would prefer
labor to be in government I think they
would be far better on the NHS and a
number of things but actually this is a
moment to come out in my opinion um I
think they should come out to say that
they would give the NHS a pay rise and
it would be 10 I think that just needs
to be said because everybody knows what
we're talking about we're all pretending
we don't know the figure I think they
need to do that because what that will
do then is I've never been stepped with
the public I have to tell you but also
we should say to the government the
opposition is asking for the same thing
if they're in your seat they would do
the same thing and it's really important
because this is important because people
keep using it as a reason it can be
afforded there are ways to do it there
are choices to be made that means this
can be why do you think labor aren't
coming out and saying that
well he'll they'll have to answer that I
mean you know for me I think what people
are looking for is is leadership you
know whenever I go into negotiation
whenever I'm in a room what you want
people to be is clear this is what I
will do this is what we want labor isn't
showing leadership well I think that
they are trying to be too cautious about
it you know and that's you know when
you're in a situation we're in crisis
now this is not the time for being
cautious this is the time to show real
leadership and in opposition you can
show leadership so I'd like them to come
out and say yes they support the pay
rise and yes it would be a pay rise in
the region of 10 I don't see any problem
with them doing that okay you've been
very clear on the program this morning
you have to say at 10 uh thank you very
much uh indeed thank you very much for
unite well as usual the take is going to
follow this program just after 9 30.
it's our chance to analyze today's
interviews talk through any news lines I
think there have been a few I have to
say uh so far on the program um we can
get a quick take now from Sam on what
stood out uh for him as Sam it's been
one of those mornings hasn't it where
there's an awful lot of news around
um what did you make of the sort of the
interview so far what stood out
what stood out to me is that well
listening to James clevery the foreign
secretary it's hear no evil see no evil
mourning there he said I'm not an
investigator I don't know what's going
on Boris Johnson has come out and said
that he rubbishes effectively
suggestions that uh the now chairman of
the BBC helped broker an 800 000 pound
credit facility for him uh a couple of
years back Nadine Sahari has come out
and said that it was an innocent mistake
that meant that he had to settle with
hmrc possibly for millions of pounds
possibly also paying for a penalty uh to
hmrc as well but critically Sophie James
cleverley came out and backed Nadine
zahawi to stay in his job as Tory party
chairman and Richard Sharp to stay in
his job as BBC chairman and this is the
thing right Sophie Richie's cinex
Administration was meant to be different
he promised Integrity in number 10 and
there's however much number 10 now might
want these to be historical issues both
in some ways links to the Boris Johnson
regime you've nevertheless got Nadim
zahawi in a prominent job in the
conservative party right now and Richard
Sharp of course was Rishi sunak's old
boss at Goldman Sachs and the two are
very very close so all of this stuff
still comes back to Rishi sunak so it's
still up to the prime minister to show
that the administration he lives lives
up to that promise he made on the first
day on the stats of Downing Street uh
thank you uh very much uh indeed Sam
we'll have much more from you at 9 13
just about 10 minutes or so when we'll
be chatting to Sam in a bit more depth
about some of the interviews on the
program today
wow it's been take a moment it feels
like it's been quite a busy show so far
I have to say so a bit of a change of
pace now because it's almost a year
since Russia reinvaded Ukraine and the
war is grinding on through a brutally
cold winter in the region and the level
of human suffering there is really
difficult to comprehend but of course
it's had impacts across the world not
least soaring food and energy prices
that hit the poorest hardest now a
little earlier I spoke to the president
of the World Bank David Malpass
I'm going to start with quite a stupid
question if I may um you are president
of the World Bank can you just explain
to our viewers what is the World Bank
what does it do yeah thanks hi Sophie
the world bank takes in money from
donors in two ways one is we sell shares
uh and we also take annual contributions
and then we provide that to developing
countries so the goal is to get better
outcome for people in developing
countries we recognize that's part of uh
being good citizens in the world but
also it supports everyone if you can get
faster growth in the poorer countries
that's been the big challenge you know
it it's uh it's not happening right now
and that's a grave concern
it's interesting you say that it's not
happening right now why do you think
that is
the poor countries are facing this giant
challenge that uh the the advanced
economies use a lot of the world's
resources and now you've got these
sudden uh uh uh obstacles covid was one
obviously the Russia's invasion of
Ukraine is adding to food costs and to
fertilizer costs uh and the countries
are cut off from World Markets so you
get this combination of forces that
causes them to fall into recession but
it's worse than that it's really uh the
the reversal and development poverty is
getting worse education levels are going
down in many of the developing countries
so it's incumbent I think on the World
to do a lot more the World Bank has been
really expanding our efforts across the
developing world you talk about the war
in Ukraine you also mentioned the impact
of covid as well
what's happening when it comes to debt
with developing countries
that is a huge challenge uh part of the
debt is in the advanced economies you
know many of them have uh recorded debt
to GDP levels and that soaks up a uh a
big portion of the world's Capital which
means it's not available for small small
businesses and for developing countries
that's a misallocation of capital and I
think it should be really directly
looked at by the advanced economies to
make their spending more efficient and
then as you look at the developing
countries uh some of them uh overused
the low interest rate environment to
borrow over the last decade so the debt
went up way up uh where we're at record
levels uh and that's coming at a time
when they're uh when their growth rates
and their new investment rates have gone
way down you know I remember you know I
think it was back in the G8 in 2005.
there was a big focus on debt reduction
on forgiveness on on writing off debt
you're obviously now worried as many are
that poorer countries are overloaded
with debt again do you think some of
that should be written off
yes I I think there needs to be a a hard
look at uh large amounts of debt
reduction by the official bilateral
creditors and also the private sector
creditors the composition of debt has
changed over that period that you name
over the last 10 years heavily toward
debt from China and also debt from the
private sector it's interesting you
mentioned the high levels of loans from
China should we be concerns about
China's influence in the developing
world
China is uh the world's second biggest
economy so I think we should expect
their their influence in the developing
World they do it both by selling things
uh into the developing world but also by
buying uh uh raw materials and by uh
offering debt so what we have strongly
advocated and I was in in China late in
2022 uh We've advocated transparency in
their debt contracts uh in that way
people can restructure them or can at
least understand what the commitments
are that are being made by the poorer
countries that transparency means don't
include non-disclosure Clauses in a
contract making it a secret contract
that that seems to still be going on
even today there's been a few things in
the interview so far that you've called
for to happen you know if you could you
know wave your magic wand and have one
piece of policy across the world to make
things better what would you choose so
much of the money is taken up by the
advanced economies I think there's a big
burden to be as efficient as possible in
government spending that that would be a
signal a forward signal to the markets
that there was going to be Capital
available for others and that would
allow the investment flows to to uh be
become more balanced that would provide
money in the poor countries for
education and for health uh and for
climate adaptation which is so
desperately needed and for food as we
were discussing uh before but right now
there's uh just not an availability of
capital at the World Bank where we have
a major effort underway with our
shareholders to look for more resources
and to use the resources as effectively
as possible to meet the needs of people
in poor countries and just finally you
know we're kind of edging towards the
end of January now what are your
predictions for 2023 do you think things
are going to ease up when it comes to
the world economy or do we have tough
times ahead
I think it's a long lasting slowdown
it's not exactly a cycle the way we've
been used to in the past and that has to
do with the Persistence of inflation the
shortage of new investment that's taking
place right now so as you look one year
ahead and two years ahead uh it's hard
to see that there'll be a strong
recovery that that puts burden on the uh
on policy makers to make decisions now
to have the spending be more efficient
that applies both to the private sector
and to the uh to the governments to make
their spending really count uh so that
there can be a recovery going out into
the future my concern is it looks like
the Slowdown or this period of slow
growth for the world may last into 2023
24 uh and uh that's a concern one other
thing I'll mention is when governments
do subsidize their citizens which is
politically uh necessary and attractive
they they need to have it be time bound
uh and targeted in other words rather
than giving benefits to everyone for the
foreseeable future uh do it for six
months for the narrowest group uh that
is possible that is hurt by the by the
higher prices that are occurring now
when you say things like efficiency and
spending and subsidizing citizens
am I right and thinking what you mean by
that is tightening belts it's spending
less it's I guess austerity slightly
uh yes exactly uh and that means making
choices hard choices and this applies to
the developing world and even the
poorest countries there's inefficient
spending and so we work with the
countries uh to to improve that one
example is uh on on taxes where the
countries aren't collecting taxes maybe
from a select group of people that get
exemptions from taxes that's not fair to
everyone else and it doesn't get the
country through this long period of
slowdown so belt tightening if you want
to use that phrase yes thank you very
much it's been really interesting to
talk thank you
now it was another dark week for the met
a serving officer admitted dozens of
sexual offenses and rapes and there were
reports that several hundred more are
under investigation right now and that
of course has led to yet more questions
about the culture and the future of the
UK's biggest and most important police
force
led a year-long investigation into the
culture of the London fire brigade he's
a former Chief Crown prosecutor he joins
us now live from Manchester thank you
very much everyone this morning
um I've been really looking forward to
speaking to you you obviously have a
reputation of you know investigating
these institutions without fear or favor
what was your reaction uh to the stories
that we've seen coming out of the Met
police David Carrick serving officer
convicted of 71 sex offenses
uh we have a police emergency Sophie
which is not being addressed at all with
the urgency it requires I mean I recall
I'm old enough to remember when the
Yorkshire Ripper Campaign Of Terror was
taking place and police told women that
they shouldn't go out alone now women
are telling police officers male police
officers that they shouldn't go out
alone and we've got a situation quite
frankly where this problem has just
grown and grown without the level of
responses requires I mean I've worked
with thousands of excellent police
officers who will be as horrified as the
rest of us by what we are learning and
morale must be really low but at the
same time any short-sighted knee-ja
response will not solve the deeply
rooted misogyny that we have here and
I've I can't understand how the
homosexual disappointed the police
without without referencing the toxic
sexist misogynistic culture that we have
in society
um last year if you remember she was
resisted our attempt to make misogyny a
hate crime so but it's not just about
misogyny we've also had racism it's not
just London either it's we've had it in
gwent and other places it's everything
everywhere all at once and I've come
across in my time several officers who
were racist sexist homophobic I always
reported them and and there are I'm
afraid so the hundreds of bigots with
Warren cards
um and there are a few things worse than
people who have power and can use their
power which we don't have
um to in effect maintain their Prejudice
and use their prejudice against other
people I don't see
I don't see the response that we require
people I think the home office in
particular exactly who doesn't get the
fact that women are now scared women you
know who can you go to I mean the
policing is a state-run monopoly there's
nowhere else to go to and right now
people are really fearful about who they
may speak to given uh the experiences of
Sarah everard and the victims of David
Carrick
it's you know hearing you speak it's
hard to disagree with what you say and
of course the iopc you know the police
Watchdog itself found the culture of
racism and misogyny in the met too
you say that the response hasn't been
enough you know what the government say
is that look they're gonna they're gonna
bump up the vetting procedure they're
going to make it easier to get rid of
you know bad apples if you like in the
police what do you make of the response
I said it's not a bad apple it can't
have it's not bad apples it's a whole
Orchid I'm afraid um they are playing
with words they're tinkering around the
edges you know what we have here is you
mentioned the iopc the the independent
office police conduct there's also the
homage inspector his Majesty's
inspectors of um fire fire rescue and
cassavory and there are also police will
also have their Professional Standards
departments none of them are doing their
job properly people whistleblowers
victims do not have confidence in the
institutions that currently exist which
are meant to be protecting them and
meant to be investigating these matters
so and also HR and people services and I
found this out with London Fire Brigitte
as I do with others the H1 people
services are meant to be a referee but
what we've found is they're actually a
goalkeeper they keeping out complaints
so there now needs to be an independent
hotline there now needs to be
independent investigatory body there
needs to be an independent complaints
process because at the moment people are
really concerned that people are not
being held accountable additionally
Sophie where is that Zero Tolerance you
know one strike it should be one strike
no words of warning no retraining
instant dismissal after due process we
can't have people as we have in the
force or forces who are carrying on as
they always have done and simply been
given a slap on the wrist and the senior
leadership have a lot to blame here they
you know there's not one non-white Chief
constable and there has only been one
ever there is a very undiverse group of
people at the top of Senior Management
and they will only rebuild confidence
when positive action is taken and I I'll
tell you this Sophie there are WhatsApp
groups and I've seen some of them and
Facebook groups one by current and
retired police officers which contain
the most horrific stuff that's where you
start I'd go in there get out access to
all of them find out who's responsible
yes absolutely the vetting is poor but
vetting only happens at the beginning of
someone's career so we need annual
vetting we need Integrity testing I
personally think the police should be
hiring or a bunch of actors to play
victims and put them before the people
they suspect and see how they respond
and we've got to get back to the
situation where we have confidence in
policing when policing realizes that
they only have this power because we the
communities give them that power
um you yeah you speak very powerfully I
have to say um you tweeted uh earlier
saying I have a lot of respect for the
Met police UK commissioner Mark Rowley
I'm sure he will attempt to fix a
long-standing issue of bigotry in some
police but it's wrong to suggest that
he's new given that he spent several
years in the past decade working in the
Met police
have you got concerns about the
leadership in the Met not with Mark I
mean I've known Mark and I know he means
well and I have no doubt that he's
absolutely determined to to change the
culture that exists but you know the
Metropolitan Police is bigger than
Microsoft Global it's uh you know 70 60
70 000 staff you know it's a massive
massive uh undertaking but also never
forget this Sophie because we're often
pointing at London and saying look it's
all in London it's happening Nationwide
and we've got 120 000 police officers
with thousands of them thousands of them
who are bigots uh who are offending in
many respects who are potentially
criminals and so it's not just about the
match leadership across policing needs
to change needs to adapt let's take this
seriously it needs to be properly
resourced to tackle this issue uh
because at the moment women people of
color minorities
you know we just do not have confidence
in policing and we have to have
confidence of policing otherwise well we
have no rule of law
now you obviously did a review into the
fire brigade and have to say reading
that report was you know one I was on
air when it when it the leak came out
and I have to say it was one of the most
kind of shocking things that I've seen
some of the details of what was going on
in the fire brigade
you called for a national inquiry
because you said that people have been
coming to you from different
organizations saying this is happening
where I work too just explain what
you're asking for well in the immediate
aftermath of the lfp review I was
contacted by I can't begin to tell you
the number of people from uh policing
from media from business from public
sector from there National Health
Service I'm telling me that they
themselves did not feel safe in their
workplaces from races from misogynists
from homophobic and the like and we we
again we can't do this piecemeal Silo by
Silo it's the whole point about the
whole society being toxic and and people
have been fearful about what's happened
to them two women two women every week
are murdered by their Partners or
ex-partners you know uh it's it's a
national if not anyway it's a global
problem and the only way we can get to
the bottom of this I think is a Judicial
inquiry as we did post Steven Lauren
Stephen Lawrence the inquiry took us 15
years to eventually prosecute his
murderers because of racism and it was
necessary for that McPherson inquiry to
take place and to really affect bring
all of this to the surface so we need a
Judicial inquiry and it has to be not
just producing it has to to be a
crossbody Society because we are in a
really bad place I'm afraid to say and
there are people who are suicidal and
they I mean there were so many people
who contacted me that I simply had to
direct them to services that will help
them they're scared they're frightened
they're in pain and there is an enormous
amount of untreated PTSD because people
are suffering in their workplaces and I
I don't think we can deal with this one
organization by itself we have to look
at it across society and that's the only
way we can provide safety a place of
safety for the people who work in our
country
just finally um we've spent an awful lot
of the program at talking about
ministerial allegations should we say
whether it's Nadine zahawi's taxes or
its loans given to uh Boris Johnson are
you worried that you know this is
effectively distracting you know the
government from some of the important
issues that we face in police and
elsewhere yeah I think I mean yes it is
a distraction I you know I'm glad that
Lancashire police went very quickly with
the seat belt all delegation but you
remember partygate took months and
months and months and months number four
fixed boundary nurses were issued and
that's policing the resources that could
be used somewhere else and should be
used somewhere else the bigger issue for
me is the rule of law uh because any
society where the powerful are able to
get away with it in the minds of the
public uh is one where the rule of law
is is under attack and we've got to
ensure that all of us are held to
account regardless of who we are what
role we have and I think that to my mind
is the bigger issue and one that I will
I'll keep on challenging people and
holding people uh people's feet to the
fire because it's absolutely essential
that all of us have faith in our justice
system
um thank you so much it's been really
interesting uh to have you on the
program I hope you'll come on uh in the
future as well thank you Sophie
and just before we go a quick reminder
of our weekly podcast if you scan the QR
code on the screen right now you can
find the sofa original Sunday podcast
And subscribe that will mean it's
magically in your feed every week now
there's highlights of some of the
interviews a bit of post-match analysis
and some insight as well into how we put
the program together now today we're
joined by The Daily Mirror political
editor John Stevens and as usual by our
show editor Scott Beasley so find that
subscribe wherever you get your podcast
safer bridge on Sunday it should be
available later today
well that is it for this week's safety
Ridge on Sunday in a moment after the
break we'll be running through today's
interviews and seeing what we learned
alongside our Deputy political editor
Sam coats thank you for joining us this
Sunday morning
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
it's time for the take where we work out
a little bit what we've heard in our
interviews uh this morning and it's one
of those days where you do feel as if
the person who is doing the round for
the government has pulled a bit of a
short straw James cleverley the foreign
secretary this morning having to ask
answer questions about Nadeem zahawi's
tax Affairs and also of course the story
that was broken the Sunday Times
overnight about Boris Johnson and the
loan of eight hundred thousand pounds so
lots to talk about this morning we can
bring in our Deputy political editor Sam
Coates shall we um Sam a difficult round
I think for James cleverley um it was
one of those interviews where I was
quite Keen to not let him get away with
the answer that they always do when
there's a particularly different round
so look I actually don't know I don't
know you're the journalist not me and
that was I guess my main aim to try and
point out well if you didn't know why
did you find out
I mean what it really reminded me of
Sophie your interview with James
cleverley was how ministers dealt with
questions from people like you at the
heart and at the height of Boris
Johnson's problems he eats Groundhog Day
to come on a morning round like this one
when there are clearly one or two very
big issues that are going to dominate
and just say well I'm too busy to find
out I mean I think he said that he was
on a trip to the US and uh and ended up
doing some shopping yesterday that's why
he wasn't really able to get to the
bottom of either story and and it's I
mean if he wanted to find out he could
have done within seconds number 10 have
access to detail about these kinds of
things there is no excuses for not
getting to the bottom of it but but in a
sent Sophie was you didn't get any more
detail on either of these two marmalade
droppers of a story one about the role
of the chairman of the BBC in brokering
an 800 000 pound credit facility not a
loan credit facility uh for Boris
Johnson when he was prime minister and
then just happened to become uh chairman
of the BBC and then separately the
question of what exactly was Nadine
sahawi's settlement with the taxman for
and did he pay a penalty and how much on
both of those stories you've got
something far more important which is
that the government's starting position
is to defend to defend Richard Sharp and
to defend Nadine zahawi and this is
really where it starts getting tricky
for Richie sunap because his whole
his whole reason for being the whole uh
thrust of why he resigned from Boris
Johnson's government how he presents
himself uh both during the leadership
campaign last summer and how he's
presented himself since he has become
Prime Minister is to draw or a line
between his administration and Boris
Johnson's Administration and make out
that in some way he has Integrity that
Boris Johnson didn't that he has probity
and is transparent in a way that his
predecessor wasn't but when you're
pelted with stories like this from every
angle and your instinct is to defend the
individuals at the heart of it and in a
sense say there's nothing to see here
then politically it does all come back
to the guy currently in number 10. uh
this government will have integrity
professionalism and accountability at
every level trust has earned and I will
earn yours those words from Rishi sunak
when he very far the very first speech
he gave as prime minister uh Sam uh
we'll talk a lot more to Sam as the
program goes on he's right actually it
really was reminiscent to me at some of
the interviews that I did during the
Boris Johnson years Grant Chaps in the
wake of Dominic Cummings for example
around uh when we're all in sort of
covert lockdown is one that Springs to
mind let's listen to the foreign
secretary James cleverley shall we he
told me he hasn't consulted with either
Boris Johnson or which is sharp
following any alleged loan guarantee and
in reference to Nadim zahawi he told me
that people's tax Affairs should be
confidential although did acknowledge
that there was a more of a transparency
expected of ministers
I've not had a conversation with either
of those parties about that about that
situation I have met with Richard we
discussed the World Service he struck me
as an incredibly competent experienced
thoughtful uh individual and I I can see
exactly why he has the attributes both
personal and professional to be the
chair of the of the BBC there are two
pretty critical bits of information that
weren't in the statement a how much does
that movement was for and B
whether he paid a penalty or not do you
not think that Nadeem zahari needs to
come out and give us these facts these
very simple facts we know that Nadeem
was a very successful businessman before
he came into politics credibly uh
successful Minister particularly in his
role as vaccines Minister
um but ultimately you know people's tax
laws in this country that you know
people's taxpayers are private matters
well let's go back to uh Sam shall we
um it was a painstaking defense wasn't
it I felt uh by James cleverley um when
I asked whether or not he thought that
Nadim zahi would survive until pmqs on
Wednesday he was like well that's just a
bit of a question designed to have a
clip what am I supposed to say that
apart from yes so he did say yes but it
wasn't exactly the most endorsed biggest
endorsement ever was it
it wasn't but I mean I think he like
probably number 10 are a bit struck I
mean the thing that um stood out to me
in neon flashing lights from from the
section of the interview about Nadine
zahalway that you just played was James
clevery saying tax Affairs are A Private
Matter
now is James cleverley really telling
Sky viewers that they don't have the
right to know whether or not the
chairman of the conservative party uh is
in dispute with hmrc because the tax man
doesn't think Nadeem sahawi has paid
sufficient tax on his shares possibly to
the tune of millions of pounds and
whether or not effectively he had to pay
backdated tax and was fined for the
result
really telling viewers that they have no
right to know that particularly given
that uh Nadine zahalby was Chancellor at
the time so in charge of overseeing the
taxing is James cleverly really telling
viewers that we don't have any right to
know that but I mean that seemed to be
the implication of of what he was saying
and and he here you get the kind of
knocks
um are all over the system if you look
over to the other story that that you
were talking about about Richard Sharp
and and the BBC you know what has
happened tonight and it's nothing short
of a tragedy is that this story coming
out means that fairly or unfairly
because it's for viewers and voters to
make up their their own mind this story
will have galvanized a thousand a
hundred thousand conspiracy theories
about the impartiality of the BBC and
and for all of our hard-working
colleagues on the BBC that that's a
tragedy so these are not consequence
free uh events and stories I I think
that there is a profound effect for
what's going on and and we are just
going to look at Rishi senac to Rishi
sunac to set the piece and work out how
he uh clears up the various messes that
that that are quite evident this morning
um because uh if he is to regain the
mantle of um and to ensure that people
trust the government
um the spotlight is on him to to set the
tone and set the direction
um uh about both of these issues it's
interesting how you're saying that it's
a tragedy uh that people will start
questioning you know the motors of the
BBC that there are consequences uh to
these stories because in some ways that
was what Pat McFadden was saying too the
shadow Chief secretary uh to the
treasury when I asked him uh about the
Boris Johnson story and also about the
Nadeem zahari story he said look this is
going to have an impact because it's
going to make people suspect all
politicians
well look I wish we were talking about
other things
um you know we might do as well things
to say yesterday about the cost of
living crisis and energy bills and so on
uh
I think the problem with these things if
you tick these different stories
together is that it's very easy for the
public to conclude they're all the same
they're all in it for themselves I do
think it's pretty extraordinary if
someone who is running to be the
chairman ends up acting as a broker to
help the prime minister of the day out
of whatever financial difficulties he
was in
uh permit Fadden uh speaking there uh
Sam I guess it was kind of echoing that
point about people's trust in
in a media in politicians uh just in the
institutions of the country generally
that's right and in the bit that you
just heard your question was do you
think the BBC is impartial like all of
those stories his answer Pat McFadden
the Labor uh from benches answer was I'm
not here to talk about the BBC and then
he gave that answer about Richard Sharp
and as I say I just think it's a tragedy
that he couldn't say yes but
unfortunately people will draw their own
conclusions there is a result of the
Sunday Times reporting uh I have to say
Gabriel pogromed Harry York fantastic
journalists who have had hit after hit
that have shaped and redefined uh our
politics so uh credible reporting uh
from the Sunday Times denials uh it has
to be said from Boris Johnson but
institutions taking a hit and another
thing is linking all of these different
strands Sophie which is you you might
wonder when things go wrong in
government or when people try and push
the boundaries isn't there some kind of
institutional pushback isn't there
somebody who's ought to be holding the
ring and going stop no you shouldn't be
doing that Boris Johnson and the answer
is yes there is and that's the cabinet
secretary Simon case and whether it's
the Nadim zahawi story about tax or
whether it's the story about uh Richard
Sharp what's interesting is that Simon
case the cabinet secretary is at the
center of it of the discussion of both
of those he appears to have been aware
of both issues and I think in the past
you might have expected the cabinet
secretary to perhaps uh somehow stop
these things he doesn't have the formal
power to do it but cabinet secretaries
experienced mandarins always have a way
or or that you can just resign if they
think things are happening uh that are
downright and ethical uh but he has been
at the heart of all of this all the way
along uh the question is I suppose has
he become a facilitator for bad behavior
uh down the years as he was appointed as
cabinet secretary by Boris Johnson and
his cabinet secretary under Richie
Sunnah so I think a lot of heat and
light perhaps heading towards him I note
that Rachel Johnson Elsewhere on the
airwaves uh Boris Johnson's sister has
basically said you all you all are ought
to ask Simon case exactly what was going
on all the way through if he says things
are okay aren't they okay I really think
that Simon case is going to be uh facing
quite a few questions but no
institutional institutions are facing
Knox they're suffering bruises and it's
just from probably not that good for
anyone Elsewhere on the Airways I love
how delicately you put that sound um
the other thing that this has made me um
this had made me think back to your work
that you've done on the Westminster
accounts project uh as well you know
when there is this deep skepticism about
money about Westminster uh about the
motivations of MPS and the work that
you've done and sky and taught us as
well to effectively put donations put
outside earnings as transparently as
possible and it's publicly available as
possible do you think that that actually
may conversely help restore some fact in
politics
I mean I I I I I think so and I and I
hope so but but the thing that stands
out with that is the stories that our
Sunday Times colleague are writing about
and and the Affairs to do with Nadine
zahari none of that is transparent it
doesn't appear on any public register it
isn't declared uh and and so I think one
of the conclusions I drew from the
Westminster accounts project which was
looking at a certain slice of how money
Works in our politics particularly to do
with MPS is that we just don't have the
whole picture and this morning is a
brilliant example of what the whole
picture might look like but we just
don't really know because we don't have
access to this information and it seems
that again the cabinet secretary uh
thinks that not putting more things in
the public domain is the right course
when it comes to money and I think
that's where the corross the corrosion
uh and lack of public Trust might come
from
um but no the very firm conclusion from
the Westminster accounts first round was
that we only know a certain amount about
what goes on and although politicians
talk about transparency love to talk
about parenting when we talk back to
them about it and ask them questions
about what that transparency actually
amounts to they're just less Keen
now there is um one other thing that I
do want to show you from this show
earlier we haven't got much time left
but it's about the strikes and I was
talking to the United General Secretary
Sharon Graham on why she believes she
would say say this government would
disagree there is a hesitance to give
NHS staff the payroll that they're
asking for
this employer being the government is
not interested in doing a deal as far as
the NHS is concerned and I have to say
we are concluding now that there must be
a much more Sinister reason for this
because this level of self-harm is
unprecedented the public are crying out
I came here at a cab this morning and
the cab driver was saying why don't they
just give a pay rise to the NHS
everybody wants that to happen it's
almost like there is another reason for
them doing what they're doing because
it's totally incompetence otherwise what
do you think that reason this one well I
think that they are looking to privatize
the NHS genuinely I believe that they're
they're looking as this is the moment
they can privatize the NHS I said when I
was on your program the last time that I
was very concerned about the chancellor
who was the health secretary who wanted
the NHS in the American trade deal and
there was a big fight about making sure
it wasn't in the American trade deal
there is something unusual going on here
that they will not come to the table
there are choices that can be made that
means we can pay for this that is not
there is not a problem about paying with
the fifth richest country in the world
there is something going on here
otherwise they are a level of
incompetence not known
uh Sharon Graham there she's certainly
had a Weetabix this morning she accused
the government of lying she said
actually just heard that they were
deliberately running down the NHS so
that they could privatize it and Sam my
main takeaway was it really feels like
the two sides in this dispute are an
awfully long way away from a deal
um exactly look I think uh she says that
the reason there hasn't been a
settlement is either because the
government is lying or because of
massive incompetence all because uh that
they've got a Sinister agenda to
privatize the the NHS I think I think
there might be just another explanation
which is that the government don't want
to settle on the terms that unite once
they don't think that they can afford it
they think it would stake inflation and
they think politically they can tough it
out
I mean it will find out in time whether
that calculation by Rishi sunak Jeremy
Hunt and other ministers is is is the
right one uh there is a separate
conversation about the future of the NHS
Ministers of course would deny that
they're going to privatize it there are
some prominent conservatives like
Sergeant Javid coming out and talking
about some quite big reforms like
charging to go and see your GP uh Rishi
sunak in the leadership contest talked
about charging if you missed a gep
appointment although he subsequently
dropped that as a policy proposal uh I I
think you can join the dots but but I'd
be tempted not to at the moment because
uh just as it stands you have uh uh you
know probably the government just not
wanting to settle on United's terms and
that will means more strikes uh to come
Sam thank you very much for your
analysis as always this morning well
that is it from safer Ridge on Sunday at
this morning we'll be back on Wednesday
at for the take 9 p.m at Sky News we'll
do William Dean zahar will still be
there we'll find out
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
this guy news is 10 o'clock